in the last video we began to visually
explore the relationship between the
number of sessions i attend and my
monthly cost given the different plans
so right here
right here in this blue line we
visualized it for the trial plan
and in this orange dotted line we
visualized it for
the basic plan
and it meets or it intuitively hopefully
represents what we already understood
about the different plans
the trial plan we don't pay anything up
front and then every time we add a
session so every time we move to the
right here we move to the right by one
session we add 12 dollars to our cost we
move up by 12 at another session move up
by 12. at another session you move up by
12. on the basic plan we did have an
upfront cost of 20 dollars but the line
was less steep we had to pay less per
extra session here when we added a
session we only had to add eight dollars
to our total fees at another session you
only have to add eight dollars so the
orange line starts at a higher point but
it's less steep and we see because of
that they clearly intersect
and they intersect they intersect
right over here
so my question to you is what is the
what is the significance what is the
significance of that point of
intersection
well let's think about it a little bit
how much do each of the plans cost if i
only attend one session so we see here
from the trial plan it'll cost us twelve
dollars while on the basic plan if i
only attend one session it'll cost us 28
dollars and you didn't even have to look
at this look at these tables that we set
up you can see this visually at one
session so if you go at one session the
trial plan is below the basic plan if
you go to two sessions the trial plan is
still below the basic plan although
they're not as far apart they're not as
far apart three sessions still the basic
plan is above the trial plan but they're
getting closer and closer together all
the way until you get to this point
right over here this point is
essentially the session
the number of sessions and if i just
eyeball it looks like five sessions but
we'll confirm that later in this video
it looks like the number of sessions at
which regardless of which plan we choose
the cost is the same and it looks like
that cost is right around 60 dollars but
once again we will confirm that and then
once we go beyond that point all of a
sudden the basic plan becomes cheaper
than the trial plan
it looks like if we were to take six
sessions the basic plan actually gives
us a lower price than the trial plan
but how do we actually figure out what
this point is what number of sessions
and what dollar value i just eyeballed
it right now and that's what's usually
what's useful about these visual graphs
but what if we wanted to get the exact
value maybe the exact value is 5.1 or
60.25 how do we get the exact same value
well one way to think about it is we're
trying to figure out the s that or the
number of sessions so that regardless of
which plan we choose we have the exact
same cost
so if we pick the basic plan our cost is
going to be twenty dollars
is going to be twenty dollars
plus
eight times s
plus eight
times s
and if we pick the trial plan
our total cost will be 12 times s
12 times s and we're trying to find that
unknown s where this value is going to
be the same as this value that that
unknown mad that unknown number of
sessions where regardless of which plan
i choose i will pay the same monthly fee
so we're curious about the s where 12s
is equal to 20 plus 8s
so we've set up this equation we have an
equation with one unknown we should be
able to solve this so let's think about
how we might do it so what's the first
general idea that we might want to do if
we want to figure out the unknown s
well for me and there's many many
different ways to approach these algebra
problems and that's actually what makes
them fun and interesting is i try to
isolate the s the s's or the s on one
side of the equation and for me i want
to isolate it on the right hand side
since i already have a 12s there and i
already have this 20 on the left hand
side i could have done other things
so what's the best way to get rid of
this 8s from the left hand side
well the easiest thing i can think of is
to subtract 8s from the left-hand side
but i can't just do that if i do that
then this equality won't hold these
things were equal to each other if i
just subtract from one side the
left-hand side won't be equal to the
right-hand side in order for them to be
equal i have to do the same thing i have
to do the same thing on the right hand
side
and once i do that
once i do that on the left hand side
these two characters negate each other
and i'm just left with 20.
i'm just left with 20 on the left hand
side
let me
i'm just left with 20 on the left hand
side and on the right hand side i'm left
with if i have 12 s's and i take away 8
of the s's i'm left with 4 s's so it's
equal to four times
four times s
and so now we're pretty close i just
want an s on the right hand side what
can i do to this equation so that i can
have just an s on the right hand side
well the easiest thing to do is to
divide both sides by four
divide both sides by four i can't do it
just to one side
and when i divide both sides by four
what do i get for s
well on the right hand side
4s divided by 4 is just going to be s
is just going to be s
and that's going to be equal to
20 divided by four
which is five
so we eyeballed it it looked like five
sessions and now we know for sure at
five sessions the cost of either plan is
going to be the same but what is the
cost of that of either plan there well
we should be able to go to either plan
because the cost will be the same so if
we look at our trial plan if we look at
our trial plan and we take and we say
five sessions how much will that cost
well the cost is going to be 12 times 5.
so the cost is going to be equal to
12 times 5
which is going to be 60 dollars
the cost is going to be 60
now my question to you is do we even
have to try that try out the 5 in this
equation right over here see what it
would cost under the basic plan
well we wouldn't because the whole
reason we got five sessions is because
we said this is the number of sessions
at which we get the same exact cost for
the basic plan or the trial plan but if
you're curious i do encourage you to try
it out substitute a 5 in here for s and
see what you get
you'll get twenty plus eight times five
which is twenty plus forty which is
sixty dollars so in either plan at five
sessions the total cost is going to be
sixty dollars and then if you add
sessions after that if you add sessions
after that because the trial plan is
more steep every incremental session
after that is going to cost you more you
see that the trial plan starts to become
more and more expensive so going back to
my question of which gym membership i'm
going to use all of a sudden i have an
interesting answer
if i plan on attending on average less
than five sessions it probably makes
sense less than five sessions a month it
probably makes sense for me to use the
trial plan
if i plan to attend more than five
sessions a month the basic plan is going
to be cheaper if i plan to attend
exactly five sessions a month it doesn't
matter which plan i actually use